when you're busy is when you should do
it that's when you should start so when
someone says like I don't want to work
out because I'm busy right now it's like
then that means that you assume that in
order for you to work out in the future
you're going to have to not be busy so
do you think you'll never be busy for
the rest of your life no do you want to
work out for the rest of your life yes
so you should start when you're busy
because that way when you're not busy
you'll be fine but when it gets busy
again you'll also be fine otherwise
assumes that you won't which means if
you wait so you're not busy to start as
soon as you're busy again you'll stop
which is what you've done every single
time before this